a movie about kids that's not kiddie I'm
in super 8 now super 8 is the brainchild
of JJ Abrams he wrote and directed the
movie and JJ Abrams when he was a kid he
used to go outside with his super 8
camera and film things and he had this
idea that he brought to Spielberg
Spielberg was like dude I used to think
of that stuff too I am in and now we got
super 8 now I'm not gonna spoil things
from this review for you there's not as
much that I could spoil as you think but
still we'll be careful I'll let you know
from the trailer is pretty much the
premise these kids are outside filming
things with their little super 8 camera
a train wreck happens things explode
which was badass by the way that train
explosion was like one of the coolest
scenes had seen in a movie in a long
time and then from there something
escapes from that train now people are
comparing this movie to ET I don't think
that's fair I don't think it's like et
and if it is like et it's not because
there's an aliens because of the kids
it's more like the Goonies meets
Cloverfield I think that actually makes
sense
Cloverfield cuz you don't really see the
alien till the very end and Goonies
because we'll kids and mischief and
awesome now if you had a childhood and
you had an imagination you're gonna
relate to this movie there's just no
stopping that cuz the whole time you're
like alright what kid am i I realized
I'm the fat kid it's the first time in a
movie that I have ever been the fat kid
but this time I am proud to say I am the
fat kid and what I like about this movie
is it has kids but it's not really
kidding the kids cus they have
conversations that are really funny like
to me as an adult
I think they're funny the script in the
dialogue it's really well-written Abrams
knows how to write some dialogue let me
tell you I mean the kids are good
they're really good actors they deliver
that comedic dialogue perfectly it's
actually hard to do but the kids are
kind of crude they say someone in
the movie actually uses their pg-13
f-bomb not one of the kids but someone
does so I don't really think he says
kid-friendly as you think it might be it
has kid mischief it has imagination but
depending on the age I don't think I'd
let a kid go see it some people die
horribly and it is pretty intense when
the intensity and the actions going down
is some really exciting if a kid
who's too young goes and sees this movie
when they get out of bed in the morning
they're probably not gonna put their
feet flat on the ground goes you know
they'll know that the monsters gonna
grab their ankles some stuck him under
the bed that's real you weren't you're
afraid of that when you were kid
whatever I was no but I didn't like
about the movies like I said you don't
see the alien until the very end of the
movie he doesn't talk he has no dialogue
he's just kind of around the alien in
this movies like King Koopa from Mario
Brothers he's pissed off he's the reason
all this stuff is happening he has a
cool ship you see him at the very end he
may steal the princess you never know so
alien is King Koopa so in
and I would say I would buy super 8 on
blu-ray it's a really good movie it's
really well-made most any human being
can watch this movie and relate to it in
some way shape or form super race
another caliber of movie but now that
I've seen it it's almost like I don't
feel like I have to see it again until
it comes out on blu-ray feel like an
awesome tak of their movie I should want
to see it right now it's like when I get
an awesome tacular movie on blu-ray not
only do i watch it and love it but I am
there in my living room with a towel a
clothespin to run my neck like a cape
while I act the entire thing out super
right I'm pretty sure I would watch and
enjoy no towels
so Goonies meets Cloverfield go see it I
think he should so have you seen super 8
what's your favorite childhood mischief
movie those movies of old that super
eights a total throwback - what was your
favorite comment below let me know and
as always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]